un nouveau drame qui émeut l'amérique
richard brooks jeune père de famille de
27 ans a trouvé la mort à atlanta après
avoir été touché de deux balles dans le
dos le motif de son interpellation
ébriété sur la voie publique
l'homme afro américain a été arrêté
alors qu'il bloquait l'accès au drive-in
d'un fast-food endormi au volant de son
véhicule
d'abord coopératif l'individu a par la
suite pris la fuite en se saisissant du
tazer de l'un des policiers
d'après le procureur chargé de la faire
richard brooks ne constituait pour
autant pas une menace immédiate pour les
agents nous avons pu conclure qu étant
donné la façon dont ces officiers se
sont comportés alors que monsieur brooks
était au sol que l'attitude des
officiers immédiatement après le tir ne
reflétait pas quelconque peur ou danger
de monsieur brooks mais leur action
refléter manifestement d'autres sortes
d'émotions
d'après les vidéos de surveillance
le désormais ex agent gare et rolf
licencié après cet événement et son
équipier n'ont laissé aucune chance aux
jeunes hommes de ce que nous avons
découvert c'est que pendant les deux
minutes et 12 secondes
l'officier rolfes a donné des coups de
pieds à monsieur brooks alors qu'il
était allongé sur le sol alors qu'il
s'accrochait à la vie deuxièmement sur
la vidéo nous avons pu voir que l'autre
officiers l'officier brosnan se donner
sur les épaules de monsieur brooks alors
qu'il s'accrocher à la vie
ce dramatique épisode intervient
quelques semaines après la mort de
georges floyd un autre afro américains
décédés lors d'une interpellation
son frère qui poursuit son combat pour
réformer la police américaine interpelle
directement les nations unies dans un
message vidéo
vous avez vu mon frère mourir ça aurait
pu être moi je suis le gardien de mon
frère
vous et les nations unies est les
gardiens de vos frères et soeurs en
amérique et vous avez le pouvoir de nous
aider à obtenir justice pour mon frère
georges floyd je vous demande de l'aider
à plaidoyer survenu au cours d'un débat
sur les violences raciales à l'onu au
cours duquel la haut commissaire aux
droits de l'homme mme michelle bachelet
a pris position nous devons faire
réparation pour des siècles de violences
et de discriminations notamment par des
excuses officielles des processus de
vérité c'est des réparations sous
diverses formes
derrière la violence raciale le racisme
systémique et des pratiques policières
discriminatoire d'aujourd'hui se cache
la capacité à reconnaître et à affronter
l'héritage de la traite des esclaves et
du colonialisme aux etats-unis et dans
plusieurs autres pays
des manifestations se poursuivent pour
lutter contre le racisme et les
violences policières